1984 la porte s'ouvre
l'air frais envahi l'espace le garçon et
la fille s'approche de la porte décide
de passer par cette porte en fait
altitude 4500 m il se jette dans le vide
et réalise une voltige en parachutisme
sportif à l'altitude convenu et se
séparent le garçon ouvre son parachute
la finul ou repas le garçon un prix d'un
stress intense à 50 mètres par seconde
c'est à dire 180 km/heure et à moins de
quatre secondes avant l'impact et le sol
la fille va réussir à ouvrir son
parachute
ce garçon à cette fille tombe dans les
bras l'un de l'autre ayant vécu un
stress extrême
je trouve que ce garçon à cette fille
c'était ma soeur et moi même article je
suis à 40 mètres une tanière d'ours
polaires pour faire un reportage sur les
oursons les ours polaires avec mon ami
ebooks ont dit un ebook des inuit qui
est déjà un pluriel
il s'agit d'aller faire des photos de
ces oursons où les ours qui sont dans la
tanière d'aller prélever des
échantillons de bourg de poils d'
d'excréments pour tracer le déplacement
de ces oursons polaires et mon amie nous
me dit ça sera toi qui ira dans la
tanière
je garde la carabine tu vas dans la
tanière je suis néo en afrique au
cameroun au coeur d'une plantation de
café je n'ai pas eu la scolarité des
garçons de mon âge les filles de mon âge
c'était l'école de la brousse faut dire
ce qui est un beau jour mes parents vont
dire zombies viens par ici daktari c'est
terminé nous allons partir nous allons
aller en france
tu vas découvrir une nouvelle aventure
tu vas voir c'est rigolo aussi ça
s'appelle l'école
de l'équateur au paul j'ai donc pris le
risque aujourd'hui est osez vous
raconter quelques en 18 minutes 18
années d'expéditions aventure je fais
donc un bon 96 où je suis directeur
d'expédition et chef de croisière à bord
de navires très haut de gamme de luxe
gm était extraordinaire j'ai fait trois
fois le tour du monde pour les faire des
repérages en amazonie dans leur clique
canadien dans le grand parc caraïbes
approché par touche la planète et je
rends barque à bord de ce navire comme
chef d'expédition et directeur de
croisière pour aller présenter les
choses aussi fascinante et belle que les
icebergs et puis des ours polaires va
naître une fascination pour ce milieu
après six années de bons et loyaux
services pour ces compagnies maritimes
de très haut de gamme
je décide de quitter le confort le luxe
les hôtels très haut de gamme le voyage
en première classe pour tenter une
aventure inédite je veux aller sur la
banquise et atteindre ce fameux pôle
nord magnétique
il s'agit de faire là le pari de
l'inconfort et de la russie rusticité
pour le coup il s'agit de partir avec
une poule k un traîneau qui est chargé
pour être en autonomie totale c'est à
dire la totalité des vivres du carburant
de l'armement des munitions contre
l'ours polaire du protocole scientifique
des vêtements etc
ted foulke a fait 120 à 150 kg il faut
tracté sur la banquise
cette poule k avancée mais la banquise
s'est pas forcément plat je vous ai fait
combiné des courants des vents démarrer
vous avez des failles de compression qui
se créent par dessus lesquels il faut
passer ça fait 10 à 15 mètres c'était
plus ans est dangereux c'est l'océan
arctique sous les pieds parfois c'est la
banquise qui sourd
il faut attendre qu'elle gèle de nouveau
ses taux pour passer dessus en toute
sécurité voilà et puis parfois bien la
poule k tombe dans des crevasses il faut
bloquer attraper cette poule k la sortir
l'art stabiliser et continuer la
progression
cette expédition se passe au moment où
le soleil est sorti derrière l'horizon
et tourne autour de l'expédition 24
heures sur 24 c'est déjà une curiosité
dans le planète et je rêve déjà pourquoi
ai-je imaginer je veux et je me projette
sur l'expédition où je veut expérimenter
la nuit polaire être un homme android un
endroit de la planète où le soleil va
disparaître vivre ou survivre la nuit
polaire être au même endroit lorsqu'il
ressortira derrière l'horizon
ainsi va naître cette expédition seul
dans le nid pollet
puisque les paramètres d'isolement ne
pas pour être récupérées en cas en tout
cas rapidement en cas d'accident de
grand froid d'obscurité permanente de
solitude et le stress du mouvement de
l'ours polaire vont retenir l'attention
de nombreuses agences diverses et
variées pour nous confier des tests des
protocoles médicaux scientifiques
techniques notamment certains pour les
futurs vols spatiaux habités de longue
durée notamment vers mars
donc je vais rentrer pendant un an et
demi soit champ d'expérimentation
incroyable de préparation physique ou
gérer jusqu'à porter les sacs de plus de
75 kg travailler sur les efforts
supramax hypo en ultra endurance et un
bon jour je me retrouverais sur la
banquise avec de nouveaux ce stress que
je connais bien
l'ours polaire nanook en innu petit ou
de voiliers la taille de la trace de
l'ours polaire l'ours polaire c'est le
plus gros carnivores terrestres
il peut faire 750 à 800 kg il peut
renifler à plus de 1 km une proie à un
mètre sous la glace en ce qui me
concerne l'ours polaire est curieux mais
imprévisible il peut passer à 200 mètres
de vous ai décidé de faire de vous son
petit déjeuner comme de passer à 50
mètres de l'ignorer l'ours polaire
lorsqu'il se met debout sur ses pattes
arrière il peut faire trois mètres
cinquante à peu près deux fois ma taille
pour observer par dessus les failles de
compression pour renifler et parfois
pour se laisser tomber
casser la glace pour attraper les
phoques 10 en dessous
et puis lorsqu'on lit un comportement de
l'ours polaire qui va attaquer en tout
cas il faut être prêt pour se défendre
en ce qui me concerne j'ai deux chiens
qui sont là pour me servir de sonnette
d'alarmé
ce sont des mâles à mouthe tucci et
michi macho 6ème alors retenez bien ce
nom c'est ciucci très bien et puis
évidemment j'ai une autre agent du
gouvernement canadien d'être formés pour
pouvoir faire peur l'ours polaire s'ils
rendent à la limite que je me suis fixé
à peu près de 50 mètres de sécurité
c'est pas très compliqué lorsqu'on
polaire cours à 40 km heure
l'explorateur et à 50 m en combien de
secondes et il sur l'explorateur
on verrait les réponses via les médias
sociaux divers et variés on fera les
calculs ensemble les paramètres météo du
moment sont en deçà des normales
saisonnières donc je vais construire
l'inédit je vais décider de faire une
coque de neige autour de ma cabane qui a
été construit par les inuit avant mon
arrivée et je vais faire cette coque
très isolée est d'abord la neige
poudreuse et puis après des blocs je
vais aller vêler accouché de congères
fossiles et qui vont me permettre
d'avoir 10 degrés de mieux à l'intérieur
qu'à l'extérieur parce que la neige a le
meilleur des zones naturelles qui soit
voilà lorsque je terminerais ma coque la
nuit polaire est installé à partir de ce
moment là je suis dans l'obscurité
totale
et imaginez que tous doivent aller voir
se passe d'un ennui total à part les
bougies les lumières d'expédition etc et
je vais donc passer 121 jours en
solitaire dont 106 jours sans soleil et
70 jours d'obscurité total voici le
fameux tableau de calcul lundi de
refroidissement éolien la température
ressentie dont on entend parler de plus
en plus maintenant dans les bulletins
météo
c'est pas compliqué à une température
donnée en degrés celsius on n'a plus
qu'une vitesse devant en kilomètres
heure et en et température équivalente
pour nous par exemple un petit moins 25
degrés avec avant à 50 km heure ça vous
donne une température équivalente deux
mois qu'a duré
prenons un moins de 30 degrés avec un
vent à 55 60 kilomètres heure ça vous
donne température de équivalente et donc
c'est pas du tout la même chose qu'au
moins 30 sur le cher sur les chairs sur
le visage sur les doigts sur les mains
sur les yeux partout sachez que dans
cette zone une les gelures sont
possibles en moins de dix minutes dans
la zone 2 la gamme de température les
murs sont possibles en moins de dix
minutes et dans la gamme de température
3 les juniors sont possibles en moins de
deux minutes
c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas concevable
de sortir non équipés de respirer non
équipés c'est du joli instantané une
cristallisation des chaires donc je suis
prêt - projet d'expulsion sur la partie
physiologie on l'a vu j'ai fait une
préparation de vraiment de très très
très haut niveau
le coeur bat entre 40 et 42 pulsations
réveille le matin au départ de mon
expédition
j'ai trahi sur des fibres techniques des
tests de vêtements et l'alimentation
mais je suis très loin d'imaginer que je
veux aller dans le tréfonds de ca bac
parce que dans les pires moments de mon
expédition je vais toucher moins 80
degrés
ça fait rêver
on ne vit que que 50% des relations et
des couples se forment dans le monde du
travail
à ce que je vois je mets toutes les
chances de mon côté voilà vous avez
entendu parler de tout type de match
imams et chima et donc la femelle qui
gravite je sais qu'avec m obile et nous
pas demandé d'éliminer tous les chiots
et je vais dire non je vais sauver les
chevaux malheureusement de chiots
survivre à l'expédition et celui ci
mishima ne lui laisse plus l'accès aux
mamelles nourricières et le rejette donc
je vais de l'air doit refaire un lot
super énergétique
je vais garder ce show sept à huit fois
par jour je vais le nourrir le sauver et
le ramener vivants
je continue toute la campagne qui m'a
été donnée sur la vision explique aux
techniques c'est catherine psychomoteur
psychologique tout ce qui a été fait
pendant un an et demi avant l'émission
tout ce que je dois remplir pendant la
mission et après évidemment je me suis
engagé à faire le circuit aux hôpitaux
des protocoles scientifiques pendant un
an après la mission et puis un mois
avant la fin d'émission les tempêtes à
répétition arrivent sont les cataclysmes
dans cette veste grand froid qui fait 4
5 kg à vide avec un arceau métallique à
mémoire de forme je découvre autour de
la tempête qui viennent le souffle à
plus 5 250 km/heure l'état de ma cabane
là je dois vous dire que j'ai les tripes
qui sont hors du jeu c'est que la coque
de neige que j'avais qui me permettait
d'avoir 10 degrés de mieux c'est terminé
et qu'il voit que juriste dans ces
conditions jusqu'à la fin de la mission
- 41 dans la cabane sortir du sac de
couchage c'est une expédition il fait 37
degrés dans le sac de couchage allait
prendre de l'ami ricoré et les corn
flakes sait déjà c'est déjà un choc
thermique de 80 degrés voici le doigt je
fais court 1 sur un format tellement
contraignant de cette image puisque je
vais devoir m'opérer tout seul j'ai une
chevelure que j'ai contracté une
infection généralisée et ma soeur mon
médecin donc j'ai prête à leur me
demandera de m'opérer tout seul soit un
rapatriement sanitaire une évacuation
soit c'est une opération et je vais
devoir prendre le scalpel anesthésié mon
doigt dans de l'eau de plus en plus
chaud brûlant jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
insensibles prend le bloc opératoire le
chirurgicale prend de scalpel et
m'ouvrir fondebrider l'appeler donc je
fais ça jusqu'à ce que le droit soit
totalement insensible
je prends le scalpel on va encore faire
trempette et jeu et je reviens un peu
plus courageux que quelques secondes
plus tôt voilà l'état de mon
alimentation pendant cette fameuse
tempête jugé pas l'énergie ni les
conditions physiques pour aller
reconstruire ma cabane voici l'état de
mon alimentation à l'intérêt même de la
cabane
vous connaissiez le mal qui s'appelait
je vous entends pas twitch yves ému
ccima qui avait mis bas et donc je vous
présente les deux shows qui sont nés
pendant l'expédition que j'ai ramené le
premier à gauche c est celui droite c
voilà j'ai simplement fait un essai
parce que d'ici j'entends pas très très
bien est ce que vous pouvez me dire
celui de gauche c'est pardon je suis de
droite c'est ok vous êtes 350 je suis
tout seul alors allez-y envoyé le
premier de gauche c'est je suis à droite
c'est eh bien vous voyez vous devenez
polyglotte
celui-ci c'est lequel
bon voilà 106 jours après le soleil va
ressortir derrière l'horizon je vais
m'engager de nouveau pendant un an à
faire des protocoles scientifiques voyez
c'est pas toujours rigolo d'être un
cobaye pour la séance j'ai des lettres
dans les yeux j'ai en fait vécu une
véritable organisation
j'ai déjà 15 10e à chacun un petit peu
de la normale je vais passer à vingt
dixième en vision des extrêmes
puis j'ai vers une audition démultipliée
puis je vais prendre du poids je vais
rentrer l'expédition je découvrais qu'au
dernier moment que j'ai pris 12 kg et
donc j'ai vécu une véritable ours
isation pendant cette expédition et se
sont tus protocole sur le sommeil et les
tests qui vont sortir grâce à cet
hivernage en solitaire l'une sur les
conséquences du froid sur le sommeil et
les thérapies que l'on en a aujourd'hui
pour aider les gens qui ont des
insomnies et également la thèse sur le
stress de performance voilà très
rapidement je saute sur notre expédition
on va me demander d'aller faire des
reportages sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique en arctique
notamment la fonte de la banquise
la fonte des glaciers avec des images
voilà je les glaciers qui disparaissent
et des zones sur lequel j'étais il ya
moins de cinq ans ou la banquise de se
former et aujourd'hui on ne peut même
plus passer dessus elle était
suffisamment épaisse pour passer des
camions et des véhicules pour aller
rejoindre les villages derrière la
montagne
aujourd'hui la banque ne se forment même
plus est lors d'une autre mission qui
sera totalement dédiée à l'ourson
polaire je vous en ai parlé aux tout
débuts voici les images rarissimes que
je peux vous présenter aujourd'hui de
cette option qui a été attrapé pour mon
ami inouk mission montrer nos mots comme
atik puycelsi puis celle ci
je demande à mon ami nous de me
rapprocher aussi près que possible pour
faire ces images sur l'ours
la maman ours et je pourrai de sortir
cette image là fort de toutes ces
expériences je vais être mandaté par un
consortium d'agents s'ils vont demander
d'aller comment vous dire ça testé des
matériels en divers conditions extrêmes
mattel de télécommunications de
géolocalisation aller faire des films
des reportages et je vais vivre quelque
chose d'extraordinaire une élection je
vais aller remettre des images satellite
à des indiens au fin fond du mato grosso
pour les aider à lutter contre la
déforestation illégale
d'ailleurs lendemain j'ai dit quelque
chose d'extraordinaire puisque je vais
goûter un breuvage exceptionnel sur un
liquide alcoolisées macérer que des ssii
indiennes et dans tes bons broyer comme
ça dans l'orne et se gargariser
avant de me resservir me donner dans une
demie calebasse que je devrais boire
c'est la bière locale
très vite pour reprendre un peu du
sérieux une zone d'observation sur la
déforestation illégale le pixel qi voyez
fait 180 km sur 180 km c'est énorme qui
est inverse la forêt qui reste qui est
en violet en mauve c'est la
déforestation alors je peux pas vous
montrer toutes les images de la série
c'est trop court dit j'en ai fait une
petite sélection j'ai autonation montrer
ça ce soir voici la déforestation
illégale vu par satellite sur une zone
donnée voilà vous pourrez dire j'ai vu
j'ai créé ensuite un projet une première
mondiale ou g j'avais très envie je
rêvais d'emmener les jeunes en
expédition avec moi en expédition
scientifique dépasser très largement les
protocoles fait par téléphone projet
pédagogique leur fait vivre leur servir
une véritable aventure quatre mois de
sélection ici à toulouse et dans sa
région
quatre mois de formation l'école de l'
aventure et qu'avec trois expéditions en
temps réel de 15 jours à trois semaines
sur la banque lisent voyagent dans les
glaces ou le concept était que chacun
des jeunes était responsable un
protocole scientifique non pas un alibi
de voyage des protocoles confié par tous
mes partenaires
la deuxième bien voilà un véritable
igloo n'est pas le même que j'avais
monté de man polaire la deuxième voie
hier des sables dans le désert marocain
trois tonnes de matériel 25 dromadaires
des protocoles diverses et variées
variés pardon pour faire évoluer la
technologie et les sciences et la
dernière en amazonie pour travailler sur
les systèmes de télémédecine envoi de
données médicales par satellite de
géolocalisation de cartographie
d'express mapping plein de choses
extrêmement intéressante
voilà je continue ce métier de testeur
puisque j'ai inventé ma vie je vis et je
crée mon vortex personnel j'ai pour
voilà allez m'expliquer dans les
conditions les plus hostiles et être
utile créé l' aventure utile et bah
c'est très excitant parce que passe par
mes mains des outils de dernière
génération comme aux demandes de tester
en conditions extrêmes de façon reste
que ça serve bien les situations
diverses et variées pour le futur et
pour les hommes au sens large
ce n'est pas parce que je sont
difficiles qu'on n'ose pas mais c'est
parce qu'on n'ose pas qu'elles sont
difficiles
j'ai presque terminé c'est la phrase de
sénèque parce que ces tranches de vie
que je vais vous montrer
eh bien ça aurait pu être de la fiction
ça aurait fait de la fiction si j'avais
écouté tous les gens qui m'ont dit vous
ne réussirez jamais à faire ni polaire
vous ne survivrez pas il fait trop froid
c'est impossible on ne trouvait jamais
le partenaire vous devrez pas de
finances
vous n'écrivez jamais de bouquins bref
tous les optimistes m le mur des
objections a été bien plus haut est bien
plus épais lorsqu'il s'est agi d'un et
les jeunes en expédition
aucun des parents ne vous laisseront
l'autorisation donnée sur la banquise de
partir avez-vous une expédition
vous n'obtiendrez jamais de partenaires
évidemment jamais de financement les
chefs d'établissement ne sont pas
d'accord les profs n'en parlons pas non
plus bref tous les optimistes une fois
de plus voilà je voulais dire ça parce
que je vais oser de nouveau et de
futures missions dans les mois qui
viennent pour 2015
après l'extrême mans froid polaire à -80
je viens de qualifier identifié après
plusieurs repérages un des déserts les
plus hostiles de la planète le coeur du
désert du namib dont les conditions sont
les suivantes 70 degrés au sol
45 à 50 degrés de température extérieure
et les vents les tempêtes des tempêtes
de sable qui va impacter d'abord d'abord
mois pour tout le matériel les
paramètres de dangerosité du milieu
alors c'est moins visible que l'ours
polaire 1 on travaille je travaille avec
des industriels sur la conception de mes
tantes qui sont un peu comme un une
station spatiale avec plusieurs
satellites
je vais tester la très haute technologie
sur laquelle télécommunications l'envoi
données par satellite des tests de
matériels de balises tout ce qui fait le
plaisir que j'ai à récupérer le maximum
de protocole la mission partira en 2015
je suis à vos dispositions pour les
protocoles diverses et variées il ya de
nouveau tous les protocoles sur le
stress la vision l'audition qu'est ce
qu'un bonhomme seul dont on a déjà tous
les paramètres va pouvoir apporter pour
cette mission là voilà c'est la future
mission que je me propose de c'est osé
je dédie cette petite conférence à aux
audacieux à ceux qui osent à ceux qui
s'engagent ce qui crée à ceux qui
veulent réussir à ceux qui échouent à ce
qu'ils ont dit j'ai fait je ferai j'ai
envie de faire j'aimerais faire à ce
qu'ils font et qui le disent rien à ce
qu'ils font quelque chose à ceux qui
font précisément linverse à ceux à ce
d'autant plus intransigeant qui
critiquent qu'ils le font rien
à ceux qui ont peur du froid ceux qui
ont peur duchaussoy qui ont peur de la
pluie à ce que bientôt auront peur
d'avoir peur je vous incite tous à
essayer quelles que soient vos parcours
individuels personnel collectif vos
projets vos échecs vos réussites votre
situation vos envies alesi essayé fait
oser oser et
time's up et n'oubliez pas que si
n'oubliez pas que si on n'avait jamais
osé on n'aurait jamais mangé d'oursins